all right everybody let's hope let's
really hope
that these are the final trump rally
clips that i will
ever be bringing you now we are in the
final stretch
donald trump did rallies yesterday in
florida north carolina pennsylvania
michigan and wisconsin
the election is today but there have
been rumors that trump is looking at
continuing to do rallies later this week
if the results aren't yet final
but let's hope that doesn't happen and
let's hope these are the ra
last rallies ever let's look at a few
clips just a smattering of the tone and
tenor of the last day of the campaign
for donald trump
donald trump shouting out musician ted
nugent who previously threatened to kill
barack obama
and predicted that by april of was it
2014
if obama no by april of 2013 if obama
won in 2012
nugent would be dead or in jail neither
was true here's trump shouting him out
ted
nugent and he is he is great where's
that
great job ted he's been from day one
right that
great job thank you very much for
everything we appreciate it
i love i love your sound i love your
music
and speaking of sound donald trump then
threatening while in the state of
michigan
to never return to the state of michigan
if he loses today
thank you very much look you can't let
this happen to our country okay
we know what's going on you can't let
this this was a total fluke
this was a total fluke in prime time it
didn't work and now
it's really not working what a disaster
i can't believe this is even happening
it puts much more pressure on me running
against a guy like this you know
do you know if you lost to somebody that
was good can you imagine if
the concept of losing to this guy
oh you better you better get out there
and vote tomorrow i will be so angry
i'll never come back
interesting tone sort of more of a
grievance tone
than a powerful tone trump here telling
the crowd you're so lucky that i agreed
to be the president of the united states
humble right
you are so lucky i've agreed to be your
president
[Applause]
go out and vote for trump and then
donald trump describing himself
as maybe maybe the most innocent
person in the history of the united
states
they were vicious they were smart if
they could find
any little morsel and they went over
taxes
and they went over everything you can go
over they spent
48 million dollars two and a half years
the mueller investigation scam and they
come up
no collusion there's no collusion after
all of that
which makes me perhaps the most innocent
man
anywhere in the history of the united
states
now this actually relates to our next
topic today trump's innocence but i
don't want to get ahead of myself so
let's continue
donald trump then making the case the
not the case just saying
that joe biden is against god
he's against oil oil isn't good if
you're against oil i don't think you're
good
that's not good politics white texan and
he's against god
now i've mentioned this before i don't
care
about religiosity when i look at a
candidate them being religious or not
what i care about is policy i don't need
a religious candidate not being someone
religious myself
it just so happens that joe biden is
actually the religious candidate here
donald trump claiming to have found
religion when he decided to run for
president joe biden actually is a devout
catholic
it doesn't make joe biden appeal to me
anymore
but that's the reality uh the glitches
keep coming
just one here trump trying to say
corrupt glitches and says corrupt and
then you see that spasm
in 2016 wisconsin voted to
fire this corrupt it and really it's
like
corrupt corrupt political establishment
right
and you elected an outsider as president
and then of course donald trump
continuing to promise that the
coronavirus vaccine will be available
now it's a couple of weeks now
unfortunately
the fact that trump says a couple of
weeks makes me think it could be months
but recall that donald trump said we
would have 100 million doses of the
vaccine
by the end of october of this year it's
now november
donald trump also promising in july and
august
that we were two weeks away from him
signing a new health care bill into law
neither has happened take a listen
listen to this
this election is also a choice between a
deadly biden lockdown
or a safe vaccine the vaccine is coming
along great
couple of weeks a couple of weeks it's
going to be out soon
that ends the pandemic and it will end
anyway they hate it when i say
we're rounding the corner it's going to
end anyway but the vaccine will make it
go a lot quicker
and what we've done with therapeutics is
incredible and then this next one i love
this is at a different rally trump
attempting to talk about beyonce and jc
jay-z
he says now i'm confusing myself because
of trump's glitch
trying to talk about beyonce and jay-z
trump talks about
beyonce which i just love they got
beyonce
and they got jay-z right jay-z
and he started using the f word you
remember in front of this graph
and it was unbelievable he was using the
f word f word f word
and the crowd is going to you can't use
that f word guys
that i mean trump uses it of course but
when when
rappers use it when uh r b artists use
it
it's very very bad and then here's trump
without any indication that he
recognizes how stupid what he's saying
is
he says republicans are disadvantaged by
the electoral college
we're going to get new hampshire we're
going to get new hampshire
yeah they say get new york can you
believe that
see the the disadvantage the
disadvantage we have
the disadvantage we have because i think
in certain ways you
campaign totally differently the
disadvantage we have with the electoral
college
you automatically lose automatically i
don't care if you bring back abraham
lincoln
and george washington as his running
mate you lose
new york illinois and california now
as i'm sure you know were it not for the
electoral college
we would have had fewer republican
presidents many republican candidates
have been bailed out by the electoral
college then trump will say well
with a national popular vote we'd run a
different campaign
okay but that that's a totally different
argument and then the last moment
it's november of 2020 donald trump
is still talking about hillary clinton
as his followers yell lock her up 34
states against
a crooked person right a very crooked
person
how crooked is by the way how crooked is
hillary she deleted 33 000 emails
what's happening with that but we won
we won we won like nobody's ever
nobody's ever won like we've won no no
the likes of which nobody's ever
we must end this we have to stop this
and part of why donald trump is behaving
this way is that he's scared
let's talk about that next